[Music]
i think the first
is you need to work if depending on how
well you want to do and particularly if
you're starting a company you need to
work super hard
so what what does super hard mean well
when my brother and i were starting our
first company uh
in instead of getting an apartment we
just rented us a small office
and we slept on the couch uh and we
we showered at the ymca and uh we're so
hot up we had just
one computer so the website was up
during the day
and i was coding at night seven days a
week
all the time um and i i
briefly had a girlfriend that period and
in order to be with me she'd have to
sleep in the office
so i work hard like
i mean every waking hour that's that's
the thing i would i would say
if you particularly if you're starting a
company
and i mean if you do simple math say
like okay if somebody else is working
50 hours and you're working 100 you'll
get twice as done
as much done in the course of a year as
the other company
well i love my work the work of the
foundation is super interesting i get to
meet with the scientists i get to go out
in the field i do think your habits are
sort of set in your 20s and 30s
and by my standards of the 20s you know
i didn't believe in weekends back then
uh not to mention vacations so i'm you
know fairly
lazy compared to myself in my 20s where
i was a true
uh fanatic you know all i believed in
was working on software
night and day and and for my 20s that
was perfect i didn't have
a wife or family uh at all
and my role was very hands-on role
you know i i'm very lucky that my
foundation work
the part-time work i do for microsoft i
see that extending
you know for decades into the future and
having an understanding of innovation uh
you know i think shaping innovation in
many of these areas
there is a unique role that i can i can
help play
work your ass off nobody ever stumbled
upon success by accident
i always believed no stone unturned
work your butt off that's what i always
believe no matter what you do
work work work it doesn't matter in what
area you're in
no pain no gain the bottom line is
one of my rules which is
work your butt off if you don't apply
that rule
all the other rules won't mean anything
i believe of what ted turner said
who is one of the great entrepreneurs
who started cnn and so on
he said early to bed early the rise
work like hell and advertise so that's
what i believe
just remember you can't climb that
ladder of success
with your hands in your pockets you must
work your ass off it's that simple to
become an entrepreneur is not
easy and and a lot of people who try to
become entrepreneurs they fail
along the way but good ones pick
themselves up and they try again they
try again until they succeed
and you know what what an entrepreneur
needs to do first of all is
come up with an idea that will make a
positive difference in other people's
lives
and if you've got if you've got an idea
that's going to make a positive
difference to other people's lives
you've got a chance
of building a business so play hard and
play hard work hard and
and you know follow certain principles
in life you know be
you know you know love people make make
sure you make a positive difference in
this world
while you're on it i know how much hard
work
it takes to pursue a dream of building a
business
the long hours time away from family
the rejection the ideas you know are
brilliant
that just don't seem to catch on there
is a great quote from thomas edison
that does the best job of defining what
it's like to be an entrepreneur
i have not failed i have just found 10
000 ways that don't work
people say you have to have a lot of
passion for what you're doing
and it's totally true and the reason is
uh
is because it's so hard that if you
don't
any rational person would give up it's
really hard
and you have to do it over a sustained
period of time so if you don't love it
if you're not having fun doing it you
don't really love it
you're going to give up and that's what
happens to most people actually if you
really look at
at the ones that ended up you know being
successful unquote in the eyes of
society and the ones that didn't
oftentimes it's the ones that are
successful loved what they did so they
could persevere
when you know when it got really tough
and and the ones that
didn't love it quit because they're sane
right who would want to put up with this
stuff if you don't love it so it's a lot
of hard work
and and it's a lot of worrying
constantly and
if you don't love it you're going to
fail so you got to love it you got to
have passion
996 is the spirit that i
encouraging alipapa people if you want
to have a bright future
if you don't want to be give up by the
society
it won't be successful you have to work
hard
i think most of the people in this world
whether the great president whether a
good professor
we're a good engineer a good scientist a
good anchor
like you you work much more than you do
when i have a shower i think i work when
i'm the toilet
i think when i running i think
we never stop working because today
why alibaba need to 996 because we
on our side we have more than 60 million
business
rely on us if we don't work hard
they lose their hope so we have to work
hard but
but if you don't like your job
if you don't like the work you do
working two hours a day
you feel very bad if you love your jobs
people like me if i love the job i'm
doing
i love the things i'm doing 10 hours a
day
15 hours a day it's nothing
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here